do you think our quarterback is really
the most valuable player
quarterback because they say like that's
the only like the MVP war is based off
of you know uh quarterback play
and the quarterback Lee makes the MVP
but my eyes like
high and I you know I I'm okay with
making people mad I I'm not a pro uh you
know I don't care about I can't make
everyone happy anyway like I can't say I
can honestly put some of these
quarterbacks in the MVP race like that
it's crazy to me yeah they're like you
know like we put I understand to God I
think right now it's down to two it's
down the two homes in Allen Josh coming
back but it's down the two who who else
would you put I'll probably put hurts in
my homes
right now
end of the season you know for me it's
hard for me to really speak on this Josh
right there Josh is probably right there
in a couple weeks I don't want him to
make me pay
now I I put my GM hat on I'll put my GM
hat on bro it's hard like when you put
Talent around it makes it easier you
know well I okay because Lamar Jackson
you put okay Lamar he he almost has his
own doing it he's doing it by himself
and then Aaron Rodgers he won he's the
highest paid quarterback in the league
not as much talent as he as he used to
having and he's not having that's why I
say Talent makes it a lot easier Lamar
okay
with Lamar speed does it change
that might be the craziest combination
in football history yeah I think Lamar
Jackson he can throw he can throw it he
he throwing is good enough to win games
and to be an elite quarterback yeah to
be one of the greatest quarterbacks to
ever throw in the ball like he has the
potential to do is he that right now I
mean he's still working on it but what
makes him special is he can take any
single play
and go to distance whether that's
throwing the ball whether that's running
the ball he can go the distance running
the ball he can go to the distance
throwing the ball you know will that
ball be you know for quarterback critics
will it be one of the greatest but it's
going to score you a touchdown you know
what I'm saying my in my eyes
can you say that if he's not leading
statistically or uh showing at any top
five category like is that an MVP I
think wins I think it wins I would say
the Eagles defense will be the MVP
I mean that defense is the offensive
line solid too no no the offense is
wrong but their defense that the defense
takes everything to a whole other level
because you know I understand the
football
like it's complimentary so if the
Special Teams gets the you know we back
about to the net uh their ten yeah or
their 20. that means the ball is getting
punted down deep you know you're not
putting as much height you're trying to
get more reach so that means we can
return the ball to about 60 50. so
they're starting almost in their
territory already so it's it's so much
more complimentary football and that's
just and people are gonna hate me for it
people Gonna Hate before I don't say
they win I think as my put my GM hat on
to to build and develop a good team you
can do it without an elite quarterback
to be consistent you need to have like
one of these top quarterbacks in the
league and you need to have a solid
defense to be consistent can you do it
without having an elite quarterback yes
you can I mean it's all type of great
players that can win games for you but
the easy route not the fastest route to
winning games or going to the Super Bowl
you need a top quarterback you need a
great defense I mean Nick Foles been
traveling I mean he's a Super Bowl MVP
Super Bowl champ so at some at some
point in his career he was performing
like top quarterback yeah
there was a point in his career where he
you could build a team a Super Bowl team
around him and he showed you that he
could yeah he Froze that guy I like
[ __ ] I like Nick folks me too
um but that's that's what I say but what
you said was Nick Foles at LEP that year
in the playoffs that's what I'm saying
but it just comes down to look
Brock
it's irrelevant who's about to bring him
up I mean Brock Oswald from uh from Rock
parties
speaking of Brock speaking about 30
speaking of Brock Purdy Brock Purdy
versus Tom Brady I'm a fan of bro I
don't even know bro
well that I had skippedo because I don't
want to save us some time but we're
proud
versus Tom Brady and I know you're
making sound like his if it's Tom Brady
versus Brock come on like it's that's
not really it like Tom Brady going
against the 49ers defense and Brock is
going against the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
defense and the 49ers defense is is
[ __ ] filthy bro like from corner to
corner into in like so I think you know
Tom is going to have a rougher day with
the 49ers than Brock you know had with
you know
49ers is surrounded with Talent Debo IU
McCaffrey McCaffrey Kittle uh kiddo now
you see Williams are we going to say is
Brockton MVP or is it the team that in
that case that's a team and Lamar
Jackson when he was going crazy this
year winning games by himself yeah Lamar
Jackson that's what I'm saying so if we
look at the Eagles is it hurts or the
team
I think it's a little bit of both man I
think
it's system I think it's a little bit of
both man because they got a great D they
got a great offensive line which helps
hurts hurts has AJ Brown and Devonta
Smith they got a good running game I
mean by Sanders they scheme that they
scheme that they have o-line I mean all
right bro like
it like and it's Eagles Cowboys the
eagle cowboy coming up ain't it yeah
it's coming up all right I'm not trying
to make no enemies all right I just like
I just love the game so much and I
understand it so much that like
I can't I like I like when things are
off I just can't like hold it in like I
almost gotta say something like yeah
you're right they got they got a great
team great deal everyone has their own
opinions like but they got so Jalen
hurts is he's good he's good they got
him for the MVP race with Patrick Mahone
his stats and what he's been doing with
the numbers that he'd be putting up is
MVP worthy just like what Patrick mom's
doing that passed through I know we
skipped over a lot of us because me and
you me we skipped up with a lot of stuff
but that passed with Patrick Mahomes was
nuts was insane bro but that's what he
does my homes is an MVP and okay and
we're going to say this Mahomes lost his
arguably you said it was going to talk
about receivers whatever because we're
saving time he lost the number one
receiver in the league right now yeah
and he's still having an MVP caliber
team he said take my best weapons he
lost he lost he said take my best friend
Tyree Houston going crazy too he is
without Patrick that's what I'm saying
so
so same with Devonte so now are we
making argument is that like because you
know we we're the only team we're not
we're not dependent worthy we're not
dependent worthy you're right so now
you're saying Mahomes arguably wasn't
playing with a number one receiver but
he said oh well and he still put up
everything he's still going crazy he's
still going crazy he don't he doesn't
have agbrone he doesn't have a Devonte
Smith he did get Tony Tony's a dog
there's Tony's a dog Juju is a dog and
uh Valdez but they're not Tyree when
they figure that uh cadera's Tony thing
up like I I looked up his highlights
right when they right when they traded
him because they traded phones like
they went and got him I looked at his
highlights bro they call him the human
joystick no he's he's ridiculous before
he do all type of crazy [ __ ] and and
that and that Andy Reid like offense
with Patrick Mahomes like when they get
that going it's gonna be [ __ ] it's gonna
be filled it's gonna be filled exactly
with Travis kids I'm super happy for Pat
like because it's one thing with your
background wall they say oh you need
this person oh you need that and the
fact that he's having a year he's having
without that I mean Kelsey's still being
couchy like Kelsey's best side of the
league like but the fact that he's doing
that like without and back against the
wall there's like how's my home's gonna
be without the cheetah how's my home
yeah and you know there's all these
critics and you know I love him to
answer he's still Patrick Mahone still
Patrick yeah I I would say it's just a
different version of Patrick Mahomes I
wouldn't say he he better than what he
was when he had Tyree Hill or worse it's
just a whole different version and then
show you how great Patrick Holmes is
just yeah reinvent himself still be as
effective as many he had Tyreek Hills
when he don't have Tyree Hill like right
let's just show you how great he is